relax rhythms are his specialty
Sasha strucken better known ins are
broken as DJ curly boo he likes his
sounds to be laid-back and leisurely
like the city that is his home I think
za Brooking is really chilled it's nice
and small you don't have to walk very
far to get anywhere you've got
everything you need there are loads of
chilled out places in saarbrücken
loads of great parties for me za
Brooklyn is just like my music
one of the places he recommends for a
visit is the now visa district one of
the few areas of the city that wasn't
destroyed in World War two
there's no reason is there now is a
district just one of the portals in the
center of Czar Bruton a tiny district
where you can just sit down and relax
when the sun's shining like today it's
great to be here but if you've decided
you only want to spend ten minutes here
be warned you could still be here a
couple of hours later that's one of the
great things about this place
the narrow streets of the late 19th
century district are perfect for
strolling and there are lots of cafes
with all its little shops the district
really feels like a village within the
city the deejay likes to come here and
meet his friends for a chat especially
after long and tiring nights at the
turntables
I'm going to show you something now it
looks like an antique shop but it's
actually something very different
d VIN sir or the vintners is Sasha's
second tip it's a place where you can
buy antiques and works of art but most
people come to sample the wines on offer
it's a place that attracts artists and
civil servants bus drivers and
entrepreneurs everyone is made to feel
welcome here all you need to bring along
is a cheerful spirit and a love of wine
taking care of the Jolly atmosphere and
keeping those glasses full is Wolfgang
grape the french-german owner of
Deventer built the shop up from nothing
he has a story to tell about each of the
items for sale he also has an anecdote
or two to tell you about the wines and
he's a personal friend of almost all his
suppliers
here's Sasha's third recommendation a
former grain silo on an industrial
estate Jesus fiona has built up what I
call an art silo with more or less no
cash people bring stuff along to help
out or they just generally help him get
the project off the ground there are
always artists working here they make
some really crazy things that I like it
because it isn't pretentious and there's
nothing else like it anywhere that's
being finished I see light rain
the industrial ruin on the banks of a
tributary of the rivers are has been
brought back to life it now houses
galleries a movie theater and studios
the space covers a total of nine floors
and you can watch artists at work as
well as enjoy exhibitions films and
video installations in an unusual
setting and on weekends here you may
spot Sasha Strucker working the
turntables